au début tout le monde les trouvait
charmant un petit groupe de dindons
sauvages perché dans un grand peuplier
au milieu de la cour d'un CPE dans une
secte civile il passe le journée dans le
quartier puis toute leur nuit dans
l'arbre
trois mois plus tard on les trouve moins
drôle tous les soirs on a 5 dindons qui
se sont perchées qui se perchent sur
nous magnifiques peupliers et qui
décharge vraiment toute la nuit des
excréments
au détriment des jeux des enfants on
peut plus utiliser du tout notre cours
tout le peuplier il y a un beau tapis
synthétique tout neuf qui a coûté 25000
dollars et qui maintenant
inutilisable cette zone-là est condamnée
parce que c'est deux jours après jour là
vraiment le saint pressionnel la
quantité d'excréments qu'on trouve à
tous les matins le CPE a tout essayé
pour les faire fuir le bruit la lumière
puissante et même l'épandage d'urine de
loup
de toute façon même quand on leur fait
peur ils n'ont pas les dindons sauvages
c'est une espèce à part je vous dirais
dans le sens que c'est des sommes toutes
petit volatiles mais qui pense qu'ils
sont des éléphants pour l'instant ni
l'arrondissement ni le ministère de la
fonte ne veulent se mêler du dossier pas
sur urgent et les entreprises privées ne
peuvent intervenir que six clients
obtient un permis du ministère ce qui
peut être très long malheureusement les
lois de la protection de la faune font
en sorte que ces animaux-là sont à
déclaration obligatoire enfin que ça
veut dire que juste un agent de la forme
provinciale qui peut prendre charge un
événement comme ça pourtant capturer un
dindon ne semble pas très compliqué on
parle pas de loups d'ours noir de d'ours
polaires c'est vraiment cinq dindon
sauvage écoutez en 20 minutes ça serait
réglé les parents aussi aimeraient que
le dossier se règle rapidement il y a
Benny caca par terre puis les enfants
ils marchent là-dedans c'est pas trop
agréable on comprend que ça fait partie
des